et donc vous êtes peu exprimé oralement
mais vous avez tweeté un petit peu
dans un tweet vous dites ce que vous
venez de rappeler je n'ai pas pris cette
initiative spontanément c'est ce que
vous nous
aujourd'hui j'y étais encouragé par des
représentants des pouvoirs publics
notamment par les membres du cabinet de
Madame Schiappa c'est ce que je veux
dire je vous le solide à nouveau
sincèrement aujourd'hui et vous rajoutez
et paraît le même
si vous pouvez un peu nous développer ce
point
les rencontres avec Madame Schiappa
désolé parce que au-delà de la chose et
de sa gravité
je suis quelqu'un d'assez joviable donc
quand il y a des choses me font rire je
ris et désolé de rire parce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure elle sera
d'autant
elle sera pas elle n'est pas mon ami
elle n'a pas été elle est pas
aujourd'hui elle sera encore moins
demain vous savez pourquoi je dis ça je
devais pas le dire dis ça parce que je
n'aime pas les gens qui n'ont pas de
courage
je ne respecte pas les gens qui n'ont
pas de courage je vous l'ai dit Madame
Schiappa est innocente mais je l'ai dit
deux dès le départ son attitude est
curieuse elle a une attitude de
quelqu'un qui est coupable mais elle est
coupable de rien et je le redis devant
vous et je lui je lui redis le sujet et
d'ailleurs non mais nous ne parlons pas
de culpabilité donc elle a une attitude
de coupable c'est moi qui le dit elle a
son attitude si j'étais un observateur
extérieur de cette affaire je dis tiens
madame Schiappa a quelque chose à se
reprocher et c'est bizarre elle n'a rien
à se reprocher écouter donc c'est pas à
vous de le dire devant je vous donne mon
sentiment
de votre point de vue voilà mais
[Musique]